[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition neil
degrasse tyson here
your personal astrophysicist and i got
with me as usual my co-host first chuck
nice jack
hey neil i like it yeah a a professional
stand-up comedian
that's just great i think everyone
should have their own personal comedian
that's just you know what i do too
however unlike you i believe everybody
should pay
their own personal comedian
see you you my friend you give yourself
away to the world you're like i am your
personal astrophysicist
ask me anything and you're gonna you say
i'm your comedian pay me i'm like
i am your personal comedian now all you
need is
uh two drinks and a minimum and a cover
and we're good
we're good that's your your currency yes
and of course i got gary o'reilly who
gives authenticity to this program
gary former soccer pro sports
commentator and we're just delighted and
honored to have you on star talk as my
co-host
it's a pleasure to be here again neil
excellent and you're not new you you've
been with us for a while but i feel
fresh every time that you come on
because when you when you say things it
comes from
places that i've never seen or heard of
and that's always good for me because
that means i learn
as do i okay so i
we this topic is mind and body
all right and in a sports context
you know we've known that the mind
controls the body we known this all
right
but we can ask the question differently
if the mind can control
the body okay can you
hack into your mind and control your
body
in ways you could not have previously
accomplished
what do you think of that and we have
today
someone who has made a career
of advising people on how to do this and
i have
dr leah lagos they say that right uh
leah welcome to star talk
hi neil pleasure to be here yeah
excellent great
great to have you here um your expertise
let me get your title straight here you
are a doctor of clinical psychology
at rutgers university and
you are licensed clinical psychologist
specializing this is the fun part
specializing in performance
psychology oh my gosh so most people
they think i need a psychologist because
like you're having issues and problems
you're saying these people don't have
problems they want to
become super human in their
mental capacity that's that's that's
badass right there
i didn't know you can get a degree in
that
well it started neil as a sports
psychologist and then the rest of the
performance world came and wanted to do
what all the athletes were doing
and so it it rendered itself to a larger
type of elite competitor outside of just
sports but it's a lot of fun
and and we certainly focus on treating
the mind and the body simultaneously for
the most
expedient and effective trainings and
treatments
so i've got you you you you conducted
risk
assessments for nfl teams
uh to to what what did you do there what
what did that involve
so that particularly involved for many
years going to the nfl combine
and working with a cohort of
three to five other psychologists that
the team also identified selected and
brought in
to do things like identify risk uh do
character profiles and essentially
the head coaches wanted to know who am i
bringing on my
team oh interesting so it's a
psychological profile of
wow and and now they would ask us
specific questions to answer so
some years they wanted us to find out
there was a year my main job for
one of the teams was to identify the
risks that each member brought on
what did they do that could cost the
team money and so they would ask
wow well there's getting right to the
heart of the matter isn't it
okay but what i thought it was was maybe
it still is is
are are they risk takers so that they
might put their
their health or and their physiology at
risk
doing something that you might say is
stupid if it fails or brilliant if it
succeeds
oh that makes sense that's remember when
remember when roethlisberger had a
motorcycle accident
and the whole city of pittsburgh
was peeled they're like who left that
guy
on a motorcycle why would they allow him
to be on a motorcycle
yeah and you find out is that the very
psychological state that has him do that
is what made him great in other things
is that a fair way to think about this
leah
it's absolutely fair that sometimes
someone's gift can also be their danger
and you have to be aware of of what
those may be
but let me get your foot let me get what
let me just get your full resume out
here so um
you wrote a book uh heart breath mind
it subtitled train your heart to conquer
stress
and achieve success so you're you're
trying to give a person
complete control of their mind body and
soul
that's that's audacious but and the fact
is that that's even possible
right i mean so you you figured this out
well
i i want to explain to you because it's
just such a dynamic world
and neil i've been doing this for over
15 years
not only do i love it but my clients
have made it my specialty
okay so first i worked primarily with
golfers and tennis players they sent me
all their friends and family
lo and behold i'm traveling on the pga
tour now i'm working with teams
then the business world came in they
knew the golfers they knew the tennis
players and
they heard about being able to control
your stress response to control how you
make decisions
like wall street's wall street traders
on the spot decision making
business oh my gosh so everybody needs
you
and everybody who's anybody needs you
well
you are the eat pray love of performance
thank you jack so
so so what's your origin story uh
bringing sort of the the physiology to
this psychology
where did that come from so i attended
graduate school
just the other day about 15 years ago
at rutgers university and you got enough
degrees on your damn wall there
you you better be an expert at something
by the time we're done here
i love it on her wall she has degrees i
have sunflowers
[Laughter]
both make people happy yeah good okay so
go on
and and afghani mishilo and paul lear
are really at the core of heart rate
variability biofeedback
identifying that a specific rate of
breathing produces a rhythm throughout
the body known as resonance frequency
and what this does is it stimulates
large blood pressure oscillations
that give you control over your
reactivity your ability to recover and
get this
your brain and what it's doing okay and
so i went up to them
during a presentation for years they had
used heart rate variability biofeedback
to treat autonomic disorders anxiety
depression blood pressure issues the
sheila interestingly enough came from
russia
they treated cosmonauts
and i i asked them neil
can we use this i'm a sports
psychologist can we use this with
athletes to enhance performance little
did i know that would lead to the next
15 years of my research
and practice well so you know the true
side of genius is
seeing what everyone else sees but
thinking
what no one else has thought and so you
took this
this very active field and gave it a
whole
other life and so just congratulations
to what you've done and what you've
forged in these efforts so
and the other thing is you clearly must
be
producing positive results
because you still have a job with sports
teams
and they give zero f's
about anything but a bottom line and
results
everything else is absolute shite
as they say because all they care about
is performance results yeah did we win
or did we lose
it's pretty it's pretty simple so gary
you had a question what was it
oh it's just going back to the risk
assessment uh just to put it in a
nutshell for everybody
watching and listening the teams need to
know
whether the pin they're about to roll
into the locker room or the grenade
rather
they're about to roll in the locker room
has a pin in it or whether it's about to
explode
because they don't care if you blow
yourself up it's whether you blow
everything else they've spent years
building up
and that's the big deal it's not just
you know are they going to cost us money
are they going to bring the empire down
and i've seen a couple of guys who
actually have done that because
nobody did risk so now i have a question
for
you guys how does one person
come into a group dynamic
and ruin the group dynamic with such
toxicity
that the team starts to lose
yeah leah is there are you figuring also
the the interplay
of of psychological states in if it's a
team sport as opposed to just a golfer
a hundred percent but what's really
fascinating and it answers your question
and chuck's is that the inability
to regulate your physiology means that
you are impulsive you can't control
what's happening in your body and often
what's happening external to your body
and i would say
those are the people that have some of
the highest risk not only of choking
under pressure and not being able to
perform consistently
at their optimal level of ability but
those are also the disruptors the people
that get in trouble off the field
the people that can't get along and
engage pro-socially and interestingly
enough
hrv is high hrv is also correlated to
pro social behavior so now
hrv heart rate heart rate variability
hrv thank you
heart rate variability is correlated to
pro-social behavior so you begin
to not only answer your question neil
but also chuck's and consider
the physiological basis for not only
health disruptions but performance
disruptions the inability to connect
with other people
being disruptive engaging in behaviors
that can bring risk to a team
choking under pressure these all have
physiological bases
because we've seen some very famous
players high paid
choke when they shouldn't have and the
opposite very
players that you rely on in exactly
those times
so you're saying you can fix the choking
that's that you just
i i can certainly make a significant
impact i had a golfer on the tour and i
have permission to
to talk about this particular piece
because he found it so meaningful to him
but
we would get to the 18th hole and he
would look up at the sign
and start counting how many putts he had
to make or not make to get to a certain
number on the leaderboard
guess what that did to his physiology
his heart rate would jump up and i could
see it
but it wasn't until i showed him on a
heart rate measure
what was happening with his heart rate
how it correlated with dismantling
he psyched himself out he
not just psyched himself out he he
basically changed the inner state of his
body so it's not just the mind but it's
his whole body
wow so so tell me
how does resonant frequency um
graft into this discussion and this is
when you spoke of it in breathing and
heart rate
when i as a physicist when i think of
frequency i just think of
how many times per second something
happens or per minute
is it are you thinking of it in those
terms or is there some other frequency
we should be thinking about here
no that's exactly the term so everybody
has the objective of heart rate
variability biofeedback
is to identify someone's resonant
frequency the rate of pre
rate of breathing that produces these
optimal heart rate oscillations
throughout the body
generally it's between 4.5 and 6.5
breaths per minute neil your
resonant frequency may be different than
mine but that's something we would
discover
either using a handheld device or going
in to see a clinician
but everyone even if you don't have
access to a mobile device or a clinician
can breathe at approximately six breaths
per minute
and derive a fair amount of benefits
from
from breathing at that rate because it's
close to most people's resonant
frequency but
what happens is pretty incredible
because it realigns
the nervous system the sympathetic the
fight or flight
and the parasympathetic the braking
action where you want to be when you're
making decisions you're
you're wanting to perform at your peak
and what happens is the systematic
activation through resonant frequency
breathing of resonance in the body
does really incredible things we're
seeing that it actually changes
the amount of connective tissue between
the prefrontal lobe
things that inhibit impulses organize
emotions
and the brain stem we're seeing that
this delivers more blood flow to the
brain so the diameter of the blood
vessels is larger
during stressful situations really
dynamic
uh physiological changes that are
happening as people breathe
at resonant frequency this is crazy you
know
leah i think i do do you have like some
uh robot in your basement that you're
programming this into i just you sound a
little scary there
we can dilate your brain stem we can
you know it's like what experiments are
going on in your basement
it blows my mind i feel like we really
as
performers only tapped into what this
does and
and i know that your parents
your father was a sociologist and a
human resource
commissioner for the new york city mayor
your mother was a gerontologist
for u.s health education these people
tend to have
really beautiful hearts that they
actually their
their gift in giving to the world comes
physiologically from feeling the world
more deeply
we actually see with those type of
people greater heart rate reactivity
those people in particular are the
people
that this from a health perspective can
be really incredible for because they
feel the world more deeply
i have to have to agree as a scientist
when i'm when i'm not starting out my
life feeling anything
really i'm just thinking things my
parents were definitely i
if i had to characterize how they
behaved how they thought
how they emoted and how they interacted
with me and my siblings they
in there was a feeling for the world and
the condition and the plight
of others i mean it was a very that
that's exactly what they were
yeah gary you were going to say
something again yeah okay so
we know that we can do these things
that's great
but what is the methodology am i just
going to sit in a dark room until i get
it right
or do i need to do a whole lot more than
just that she's going to chase after you
on the golf course stop looking at the
leaderboard stop
give me give it give him my age and
knees
yeah so how does this work what are the
mechanics of this leah
so the scientific process of this is 10
weeks breathing at 20 minutes twice a
day at your resonant frequency again if
you don't know your resonant frequency
you can just start at six breaths
per minute a four second inhale through
the nose gently
and a six second exhale through the
mouth as if you're blowing on warm soup
people want to accentuate the inhale
wrong the
exhale is what really stimulates the
vagus nerve
we want to have that little itty bitty
pressure like
you have a soup spoon in front of you
and you're blowing on it
interestingly enough but just remind us
the vegas excuse with the vagus nerve
does what
just remind me makes you spend money
neal at the slot machine
the vegas nervous responsible for all of
your poorest decisions
in life
okay now we got that out of the way now
i've heard of it i just don't remember
what it is
the vagus nerve does what the vagus
nerve travels from
the midbrain innervated through the
heart all the way to the digestive tract
it's a super
information highway that carries
information throughout our systems
when we produce a specific frequency
resonant frequency
it generates what's called 0.1 hertz
from the heart and guess what
thank you vegas nerve super information
highway it sends those signals to the
brain and the digestive tract so
when we've done mris this was conducted
by my
colleagues and friends at rutgers they
looked at mris of individuals who had
engaged in
a few minutes i think it was five
minutes of resident frequency breathing
the 0.1 hertz that they produced in the
heart from the resonance breath
was emitted they could find 0.1 hertz
all over different fears of the brain
spheres of the brain i would argue
that's flow okay i just got to jump in
here so
uh audience leah using the word hertz
doesn't mean anything
caused pain this is heinrich hurts a
german
physicist from 150 years ago
who basically pioneered electromagnetic
our understanding
of electromagnetic energy and the unit
of
frequency is in his name in his honor
all right so cycles per second one cycle
per second is one hertz
so so you're you sighted one tenth of a
hertz
so one tenth of something happening per
second
means it's one thing happening every 10
seconds
and that's six breaths a minute so there
you go i just want to just make sure
we're all on the same
arithmetic page there so doctor i don't
have 20 minutes during a game which was
excuse me i'm going to go and breathe
and come back and be and be in this
wonderful
state so is it a pre and post
performance
exercise or can i teach myself to
once there's a little break in a game
and it can happen in nfl or basketball
or
baseball can i just dial it up bring it
on
dial it down and move on or do i have to
go through 20 minutes of breathing here
no so that's my specialized protocol and
and i've been
working with athletes and people in the
hedge fund world for
several years doing this now getting
them to one breath in one breath they
can access that flow state and we've
practiced this so
the 20 minutes twice a day increases the
baseline let me tell you what it does
you do 10 weeks 20 minutes twice a day
nothing else
you're able to reduce anxiety improve
your mood enhance your focus
increase cognitive dexterity the ability
to think thoughts quickly and let them
go
but then in the moment to actually
control your stress response and be
really precise from
flipping from a stress state to a flow
state it's something we can practice and
we can train
that takes some clinical work and we do
that in my office
but gary i've gotten traitors and
also golfers and basketball players and
quarterbacks
down to one breath where they've trained
to be able to activate
that parasympathetic dominant state in
just one breath and it's really powerful
because when you can activate the
parasympathetic state
you increase your objective decision
making you also as an athlete increase
fine motor skill you're a golfer you're
a tennis player
you're you're doing your foul sean on
the nba
free throw line this all impacts your
ability for precise muscle movement
well guys we got to take a short we got
to take a short break but when we come
back we can have more from dr
liat lagos and this heart rate
variability bio
feedback system that she's talking to us
about but in particular
we're going to see how this applies not
just to athletes
when star talk returns we're back star
talk sports edition we're talking about
mind
body uh what's in control of what and
how and why
and we've got dr lea lagos with us from
rutgers university and this is
her specialty uh leah welcome and we are
just the idea that
psychology and physiology
are blended together almost
indistinguishably
in your work i think is just
extraordinary and something else we
learned about looking at your background
you've spent many years working on
patients who have post-concussion
syndrome
so first what is that and how do you
rehabilitate them using your methods
so neil the majority of athletes with
sports related concussions
recover within seven to ten days and
non-athletes within about three months
but there is a cohort of athletes and
non-athletes
that simply don't recover they don't
follow the trajectory for natural
healing
and as a result what happens is
they can have a year where they're
looking at the ceiling they're not able
to read they're not able to participate
not only in sports but in school
so at the university of miami i was
working with their athletic department
and specifically
their sports medicine department called
me and said can your bio feedback
thing these athletes from concussion
can your magic work on us
because we don't know what to do we've
tried and you're a sorcery couldn't get
it too
so what i said to them neil was at the
time there wasn't
a lot of research that this would help
in a meaningful way so i didn't over
promise i said
all i can say is this is a process that
absolutely will reduce anxiety
improve mood and enhance focus they go
we're sending them to you and lo and
behold my first athlete
uh her name is samantha sanderson i have
full permission to talk about her she
actually has her phd now
in sports psychology clinical psychology
and guess what does biofeedback because
she said it changed her life
she came to me having experienced
several concussions and this
time she wasn't healing she couldn't
read she couldn't participate in sports
what sport did she get the concussion in
soccer
soccer oh gary but gary you didn't tell
us about this gary
i didn't do it you're sitting on your
ass right there and we're talking about
concussions
yeah i know yeah yeah all right okay
it's not the ball
sometimes it's uh an elbow or or your
head against someone else's head
yeah there's a lot of different ways to
to to have okay
so yeah all right all right and so you
have the physical injury itself
and then you have the other
psychological pieces like being
fragmented or isolated from the team
you've been playing with this team for
three years and now you're in your room
with no contact
because you you can't be part of sport
so anyway we went through biofeedback
around week seven she came to me with
tears
pouring down her cheeks i said sam
what's wrong she says no
doc these are happy tears she goes i
read my first book
in six months harry potter cover to
cover she said i just kept reading i was
so excited
and she said doc it's the bio feedback
and i said well let's not get excited
let's just keep going through this
and her her trajectory was that her
symptoms
her natural healing process that had
been stilted for all this time
began and what's fascinating and so i've
used this with over a hundred athletes
with post-concussion syndrome over the
years
is there is a whole cohort of research
that now supports why this is such an
important piece
for physiological recovery that
concussion is not just an
injury to the brain it's an injury to
the entire autonomic nervous system
you get hit in the head and the entire
autonomic nervous system goes like this
with sympathetic
dominance very very high and
parasympathetic
under activation the parasympathetic
nervous system is injured
and until those rebalance you are in a
stilted place
where you can't the healing process
can't actually begin
so i i've used this with just many many
athletes and i will tell you
it's been life-changing for so many that
couldn't heal otherwise
leah i've seen gary stare up in the
ceiling and he doesn't read anything
because
can you make him your next patient
[Music]
there are some things a doctor can work
with and be successful and then there's
me
no okay so what sort of timeline i mean
you've answered the question about
what's blocking
the recovery because i mean people must
have come to you in the beginning
and like we don't know what to do yours
now
and so and then you work out what the
blockages are and how you move the
pieces aside and reconnect
but how long i mean we talked about 10
weeks
with being able to develop your
methodology and techniques but with a
case like this how long does this take
well we've seen meaningful improvements
in 10 weeks so by in
in 10 weeks we will see improvements in
cognitive functioning i'm not saying a
cure
i'm saying improvements in the ability
to focus
a lot of times people to read i will say
pro-social behaviors return
people that have concussion often feel
they can't
socialize and connect as a human being
anymore
and it's devastating to them but how
much do you expect
how much recovery do you expect in 10
weeks even if you never showed up
and and what if you were always an
a-hole even before the concussion
question
i don't know why i don't know why i
can't connect i can't seem to connect to
people
no matter what i do maybe you should try
not being an a-hole so much
and people wouldn't mind talking to you
at the cocktail party
so we'll bring it back to science and
and i'll say
that you know i have had many athletes
with concussion go through several
iterations of 10 weeks they've been with
me for
sometimes a year or a year and a half to
complete their recovery but
but it's meaningful and it's often
individual specific so i think it's
really important to
to to say you can make
significant gains in 10 weeks but often
with concussion
it extends beyond that post-concussion
syndrome in particular
and that you may have to do several
iterations that's the pcs that lingers
so now what about what about those who
haven't had a concussion but want to
achieve those same results
what is how do you establish a baseline
for those people because a concussion is
an easy baseline
it's like this is what i was before now
this is what i am now
how do you go from if i'm just joe
athlete who wants to
do all of those things but just up it to
a level
how do you as the clinician establish
the baseline
so i look at their heart rate
variability and what's really
interesting chuck is
i think everyone should know their
baseline heart rate variability and
monitor it it's certainly used for
runners
and endurance sport to assess over
training
hrv will dip about two standard
deviations sometimes less one standard
deviation
when people have over trained so coaches
will monitor it to adjust practice
but if we have that baseline then when
someone's concussed
we can also look at their hiv to
predict have some physiological
prediction for recovery
and an understanding of what has been
injured
during the concussion itself so it's a
whole new universe of data
it really is a whole new universe of
data my gosh
sorry neil is there a point doctor where
if someone's had a concussion
a serious concussion like anyone's none
of them aren't serious i
understand that if is it a year two
years three years is there a point
this has been in place too long i cannot
undo what has been done here or can you
go through we haven't said that yet
and that's a hundred plus athletes so i
will sometimes
graduate the client uh into
neurofeedback particularly if they're
having focus issues
and neurofeed so heart rate variability
biofeedback is going to realign the
autonomic nervous system
and gender greater blood flow and oxygen
to the brain
but neurofeedback will help them emit
specific brain frequencies
that allow for cognitive focus
for greater flexibility and so sometimes
we'll do that if they're still having
attention issues sometimes hiv
biofeedback for concussed patients
doesn't mend the the focus piece as
tightly as they want and so then we'll
add the neural feedback but it's been
incredible
clients that essentially were staring at
the
room of their bedroom for nine months
with no
treatment that was working we worked
with for
six months to a year using just
biofeedback and had incredible gains
and then using neurofeedback for just a
few months
and they're off to college and just
doing brilliantly and sending us letters
it's it's really truly incredible so
what about wall street traders these are
high
these are high strung people where they
have to make split decisions that could
cost
millions and what is the
challenge that one needs to overcome
here
they're just high strong people that so
where do you come in
i would i would exchange high strung
to high brain activity lots of brain
activity
all at once and and the ability to think
of lots of things
at different levels and that's what
they're great at and that cognitive
processing speed but a lot of them can't
turn it off
and that's a problem for sleep that's a
problem for focus
it's a problem for decision making also
um just people who are making rapid
decisions and needing to perform at
their peak meaning
integrating contextually lots of
different information
at once to make decisions people
in in the trading world are really
gifted at it but you start to add
stressors like losing money
and it changes how the brain works that
brain that can take so much
contextual information becomes myopic or
fragmented because they're under stress
and the difference there with an athlete
if they train they get
become a better athlete whereas in
when they train but with wall street
traders there's still this
betting aspect this sort of las vegas
what are the odds that you'll win aspect
to it and they will all
eventually lose sometimes if not most
times
right so that's not even something that
even if you're really good
you can't guarantee against it so that's
that's a given with every one of them
right
that's right and what's so interesting
neil and i've seen it with golfers and
i've seen it with traders
is after the win that's some of the most
dangerous time for the next play whether
you're
you've just you've just made a birdie or
a hole in one on the golf course
there's all these neural chemicals
lavishing your body and it actually
changes
how you think and how you perform and
the same thing happens with traders
on wall street they make this great
trade they make hundreds of millions of
dollars and guess what
it changes how their brain operates for
the next trade so they have to
also engage in the ability to have
precise control
training to have precise control over
their physiology to
to remove that danger but what you're
saying is objective
consistent decision making and and how
do you do that
and this goes back to what gary was
talking about in just
a few breaths you have to take 20
minutes no
during the actual trading day we get you
to a place where you can take
a breath and you can put yourself in
what's called
low frequency heart rate and activate
the parasympathetic nervous system in
just one breath
to be able to engage more fully that
cognitive dexterity and processing
yes this sounds great because we've got
people in charge of our money that
we need to be focused but what's
different from
the single mother with two kids who's
working two three jobs and is stressed
and when you talk about a lot of brain
activity they've got to keep those kids
entertained they've got to get
better so where keep them alive yes
thank you
so there's a motivation that you know
what my wall street trader can go home
to their 50 million
penthouse this single mother's got to
find the rent
at the end of the month the brain
activity is intense so what difference
is that
mothers managing lots of different tasks
at home
and and needing to control their
reactivity when there's three kids
crying
and needing to stay calm under pressure
very
very much kind of the same type of
need as someone on wall street or or
someone needing to make a putt
being in control having precise control
over how your body responds to stress
and it just has so many different
applications
what is what what you're saying not to
put words in your mouth is that
since more than athletes endure stress
in our lives this system of
understanding and manipulation of our
own
mind and body has no end of applications
in this world
exactly right and
there is even a new application
about bias and discrimination the the
newest application of hrv
is looking at how hrv heart rate
variability
serves as a buffer to the effects of
discrimination
and engenders empathy so people can
control their inner biases
when when reacting and interacting now
are we talking about the recipient of
racism
or the progenitor of racism
because those are two different things
two different sides of that fence right
there
yeah but it both is what i'm saying
simultaneously the person
who has received a racist comment if
they've gone through the hrv training
the effects of discrimination have
actual physiological impacts on the body
higher blood
pressure greater heart rate more um so
forth cardiovascular believe me
believe me i know that is because what
happens is somebody will say something
racist
you like
okay please that's right it's all i
could do to keep from killing this
person right now
and the other the other end which is
fascinating to think about
in in the world we live in today is that
people
have more control over their inner bias
because they have
more control over their inhibitory
mechanisms in the prefrontal lobe of the
brain through hiv biofeedback so
what i'm suggesting and research is
mounting research is showing is that hrv
biofeedback
helps people of all walks of life
have greater control over their inner
bias
and also increases their empathy towards
the other person so it works both ways
okay i have a practical question before
we take our
our last break is if i'm a sprinter
and i'm on the starting blocks and i'm
anticipating
the the starting gun or they don't use
guns anymore the starting sound the
starting tone
um don't i want my heartbeat to be
ready for that don't i want i mean what
what's so bad about
a high heart rate i mean i guess i'm
trying to understand
what how that information is folded back
to
what is called what you would call
therapy in that situation
sure so the one piece of this that i
think is really important and i love the
question you asked neil is
is this just a calming exercise and it's
not
it gives you more control over how you
react if you need to amp
up you can amp up faster if you need to
let go
you can let go faster wow so it gives
you precision in both directions
so it gives you control knobs on your
body yeah there you go
oh my god you just dial it up dial it up
or down
oh that's right neil i had an nfl coach
a year ago come in and and he came in
for a specific reason and but he said to
me doc i can't make you
you can't make me like i just came out
of yoga class i need to be able to
still yell and control
i had to promise him up and down he
wasn't going to lose that edge he was
going to
enhance both directions and by week 7 he
came in he goes oh my god you're right
i'm so glad i trusted you but it was so
hard for him to trust
that we weren't just going to calm him
that is funny if the nfl became a
one big yoga class that would be funny
uh so listen here
ladamian i know you've had four fumbles
in just the last four possessions but
i'm breathing now and so it's okay
i just want to let you know buddy
everything's okay
go out and fumble number five
but what i want people to understand is
is that
it it means a quarterback can amp up and
and make decisions and and get into that
performance state faster and then let go
for recovery and what's so fascinating
is by week seven of this process
most of my athletes have greater
endurance do you know why that is
there's a cardiovascular energy savings
because the gas exchange has been
optimized
meaning there's less co2 in your body
more more efficient that's right
and so my olympians my pga tour players
my elite level collegiate runner
come in and they say what is going on
doc i can run faster i can
play my sport longer and i'm not
changing my training it's the hrv
okay so let's move over to the psych the
psychology of this
okay based on what you just said and
what neil just said
as a comedian i kind of get
off on the hype before
the show all right now based on what you
just said
all that expulsion of energy and
everything i feel exhausted in such a
good way when it's over
but i'm gonna say that it's become
a bit addictive it's like the high
i want to do the next show because i
want that
high again i also want to experience
the come down off the high the return to
normal
so for somebody like a comedian or a
performer
all right what would that do to me
because i
it sounds good isn't leah just telling
you that
now it won't happen spontaneously you'll
control it
you'll say i'm ready to go on let me
it's time to get hyped up i'm just
coming off the stage now let me come
down
you're just in control of it the
spontaneity though
is what creates the addictive quality to
the experience
you don't want to be addicted to
anything no i want to be addicted to it
we're going to take a break when we come
back more with dr leah lagos
and we're going to discuss whether or
not kovid put the whole world
in a stressful state and see if she can
fix that
when star talk returns
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about the mind and the
body the two-way street that they
can be as enabled by the expertise and
studies of dr
lea lagos and again welcome to star talk
and i got chuck nice here tweeting at
nice comic thank you
and uh and gary you're tweeting at my
three left feet
is that one right that'll be me i got
that right wow yeah
and leah you you have a social media
presence i do
dr leah l-e-a-h logos lagos
on twitter okay excellent when we left
off chuck you you dropped
a a question like a bomb and we didn't
have time so bring it back in what
all right based on what you guys were
talking about in terms of being able to
control
the experience does
that lessen the high
that you that the performer feels from
the experience itself
the fact that you are creating it for
instance when i go on stage at that high
i'm it's it's spontaneous and so i'm
seeking it each time
and i'm going to echo chuck's point when
i give a public talk
and if there's high anticipation it's in
a theater and and
there is this sort of anticipation that
i'm not controlling
but it sort of puts me in a place that i
want to be
and need to be to deliver for that
entire
lecture and then at the end when it's
over there's this
fascinating descent that is actually
quite pleasurable
except completely exhausting just
because all the energy was focused in
that time i think i'm saying the same
thing
chuck is saying so are you doing a good
thing by removing
what happens automatically and
spontaneously within us
so i'm not removing it i'm amplifying
and so in those situations where you're
having a state that's desired this will
allow you to amplify that state
even if it's happening holistically on
its own
and the energy management piece would
just be tighter at the end
to the extent that it would help your
body to recover it's not going to
reduce the pleasurable piece and in fact
i would
i would argue it would amplify the the
positive
maybe euphoric is too strong but the
positive
adrenaline dopamine state in the
beginning
and and then the descent is still
experienced so
what happens with this which is really
phenomenal
is it amplifies desired states and
in states that aren't so desired the
ability to feel them and let go happens
faster
i tell people that people that also feel
the world
here feel the world you can't see my
hands if you're listening on the radio
so i'll just say they're wider
okay a wider range because the reason
you're able to feel wider emotions and
it's really important also for
people on wall street to be able to feel
a range of emotions because so much of
their decision making
there are somatic cues that will happen
before conscious cues come in that they
have to listen to
but you feel a wider range of emotions
because your body
feels that you can let go faster so my
short end answer is
you would you it would amplify the
experience so leah
you're i'm guessing i don't know for
sure that
the your book costs less than a one hour
session with you
so for those who can't afford you or
can't find you or if you're too busy
with big old fancy sports teams i
presume
there's some insights that we get from
your book heart breath mind
train your heart to conquer stress and
achieve success am i
is that a fair plug for the book yeah
thank you so much now my
objective in writing the book was to
bring a process that has been so
meaningful
and by by description of my patients as
life-changing
to the world and the people that can't
come into my office and it allows people
to take mobile devices
breath pacers on their phone heart rate
variability monitoring
and use different types of applications
in their own home
to still gain many of the benefits of
this process
all right now let's get down to brad
brass tax we're coming off a year
if we're still in the the an extended
year
of a covid pandemic and
it's basically you know the year the
earth stood still right
uh we uh industries came to a halt
people were washing their groceries
kids bouncing off of walls not in school
in daycare and nursery school
this is a this is trauma for lack of any
better word do you have a way to
heal the world the whole world
beyond just the individual well
i believe we all have been experiencing
trauma through
people fragmented from families people's
just daily routines can't engage in
self-care and
losing loved ones they can't even hug
them on their death beds there's
it's it's traumatic it's so traumatic
and then there's the peace
where the uncertainty the not knowing
where this ends the not knowing what
tomorrow brings
that in influences our bodies
in a traumatic kind of way too what it
does is it engages sympathetic
activation
a sustained state of hyper vigilance and
many people so people will say
i'm not sleeping well right now i feel
depressed and
and i and it's just kind of ongoing or
my mood is slipping
there's physiological reasons for that
many
and most people are feeling a heightened
sense of
of not being safe in the world and
that's internalized in their body in
their autonomic nervous system
so it's not just let's fix the brain and
your body follows
it's the body can have feedback onto
what the brain is doing did i learn
anything in this session with you leah
and specifically the heart and so the
heart is embedding these experiences as
frequencies in the heart that then
impact the brain
and it's unique and i believe it will
lead to a paradigm shift in treatment
and performance
when we start to address physiology
first
and then we add the psychological
techniques i can tell you my own
clinical experience
i can have you on my couch for three
years and we can talk or i can train
your physiology and i
can get you to places through talking
that are much faster and more effective
after we've gotten you to manage
how you respond to stress and let go
tim ferriss talks a little bit on his
podcast healing
about healing trauma and his experience
working with me
using heart rate variability biofeedback
to decrease his cardiovascular
reactivity to stressors that because of
of trauma he had a heightened reactivity
to specific stressors
and what that often engenders people to
do then is to go
deeper even into other forms of therapy
because
they're not in that hyper-vigilant
fight-or-flight state
they can allow their body to go into
that deeper terrain
for healing so if we are having a
paradigm shift
and we're using physiology to work with
the psychology
are there other areas of clinical
medicine
that we could move this technique into
and be successful
yeah how about fears how about fears
people who are afraid of flying or obs
phobias especially phobias yes that's a
great one and and i
i have many patients over the years who
their phobias have
significantly reduced if not disappeared
and i had one woman
who had uh phobia of planes hadn't been
on a plane in eight
years and we got her not only on a plane
but actually able to go through the
entire plane ride it was a three-hour
plane ride without a panic attack i mean
it's really profound and she had her
heart rate variability monitor she had
her breathing protocol
we planned it just like it was an
olympic game
and she had a strategy for how to shift
her physiology before
during and after that that plane
experience well i have to just say
that's a first world problem i haven't
been on a plane in
eight years people in the world have
never even seen a plane
yeah much later first world problems
there
um no but that is interesting so that
was able to you were able to overcome
that that's
so hopeful oh my gosh so now it sounds a
lot of what you're talking about
sounds vaguely or slightly related to
mindfulness and mindfulness and
meditation yeah meditation what's the
difference between this and meditation
is the difference yeah
and and is can that be kind of a a
gateway to you or can you be a gateway
to that
and frankly you sound more sciency to me
than anyone who i've ever had a
meditation conversation with
so so if you can just tell me what
what what's the difference in and is one
and what's the overlap so i meditation i
think is beautiful and i'm
a big supporter of it but it produces
different effects
so i have people who have been
meditators for years and they still have
high blood pressure or
they can't sleep at night or they can't
perform under pressure
and so this specifically from a
performance perspective is something
that you can use
during performance moments to shift from
that flight or fight state into a flow
state and that's really important for
performers so
meditation doesn't doesn't quite yield
that effect um
the the other piece is that what you're
developing through 10 weeks
is you're transferring the heart rate
oscillations they're like
big beautiful waves when you breathe at
your resonant frequency versus just
regularly
so let's say your heart rate goes from
60 to 70
so as you inhale it goes up 60 to 70
goes down
per minute breaths per minute thank you
and then 70 to 60.
but when you breathe at your resonant
frequency it goes from
60 to 90 and 90 to 60. so they're
bigger oscillations and what happens
through the 10 weeks is those
oscillations that you're practicing
systematically 20 minutes twice a day
begin to transfer over to your baseline
so then
you start to see increased heart rate
variability like when you
were breathing at resonant frequency but
at your natural baseline state that
doesn't happen in meditation
okay okay okay take that meditation
take that yogi
[Laughter]
uh so i this this is all sounds so uh
hopeful for so many people who might
have had
un intractable problems that
are don't otherwise yield to
simple therapy medication or anything
else
uh so you why why aren't there statues
to you
out there
well i my hope neil and and chuck and
gary is that we really educate the world
so they understand the powerful benefits
it's really life-changing for so many
people and we're in a world right now
where
everybody can use this to thrive in
their own
personal performance and health domains
well i think that's where we're gonna
land this plane right on that bullseye
uh leah it's been a delight to have you
on star talk
and as you know we try to find other
angles on sports
that are informed by science and you did
exactly that for us today so thanks for
being a part of this
this this effort and uh gary always good
to have you man
pleasure was mine always learning always
open to that
and she'll fix that concussion thing
you're still going through we'll we'll
get back to you
just hit me on the other side of that oh
that'll balance it right out
all right this has been star talk sports
edition neil degrasse tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist keep
looking up
[Music]
you